và đau đêm mê sư tập lắp tốt, trên sẽ quên gây an bị tóm.
Chúng thống mời nơi ngàn công trọng hay bị tư.
Tại khu gí túc xa sinh viên phía đông đả nắng,
sẽ ra hàng loạt phụ chộ lắp tốt,
lần xinh viên hoang mang và anh gửi đến được học tập.
Chức tình như này, công an cỡ hành sơn,
đáp phối hợp với công an phụn khuếc bí truy tìm tù phạc.
Qua đều tra, lực lượng công an nhận thấy không có dấu hiệu được đập phy bếp ngoài.
Nếu khả năng, tụ phạc là người dục trong ký túc xa,
sau khi quên vùng hợp phát hiện lệ văn phủ,
xin năm 20 năm 2020,
chú tệ vị quyết liệu,
mê ăn,
có nhiều biểu hiện bất mình.
Ngày 20, hai tháng mời,
qua khẩn trà hành chính,
phố đã thử dân từ đau tháng mời đã chục năm lắp tốt vào bột tiệt thạc
tức khóng trong ký túc xa,
bán chuh hồ bảo miệng,
người tạm chú tệ để chỉ ba chăm năm 20 xa chết bà của hành sơn.
Mà ra,
tổn trà công an phường biàn đã bất sữa cao tị tư dàng
xin năm 20 năm 2020,
sau khi coi chọn chức mắt bốt bờ bờ mờ mờ mờ chỉ sạm bốn mi chuyện đồng của anh đi quyết hợp.
Tong ngày 20 xa tháng mời,
qua định vị,
trước lắp tốt bị mắt được tình tới tại một nảnh trọng trên đường át tự vời,
sang cũng khai nhận thêm,
việc chục cấp nhiều lắp tốt với địa vải khác ở khu vực u hành sơn.
Như vậy, vì muốn nghen trong có thể để thỏng vãi nhiều cầu án trời của bản thân,
lế vấn vũ vật cao tị tư dàng đã tự đồng sắp cái cờ bất vật ở nài.